der bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
hat vor einigen monaten gesagt dass man
in einer zweiten corona welle nicht
nochmal die geschäfte schließen müsste
wie bitter ist das jetzt mit so einer
ankündigung mit so einem versprechen den
sachsen brechen zu müssen
wir haben das versprechen nicht
gegebenen ganz im gegenteil wir haben
immer wieder gesagt dass wir hier diese
maßnahmen entscheiden müssen auf sicht
denn es ist wie drehen eines films ohne
drehbuch
wir sind in der verantwortung ohne dass
jemand sagen kann was richtig oder
falsch ist sondern wir informieren uns
wir diskutieren und fallen mit
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern und trotzdem müssen wir
entscheiden und abwägen und wir haben
alle gehofft dass die zweite welle die
kommen wird das wussten wir von anfang
an dass wir sie auch so im griff haben
dass wir eben keine geschäfte schließen
müssen inzwischen sind wir auch in
sachsen an unserer kapazitätsgrenze im
gesundheitswesen angekommen heute gab es
ein hilferuf der dresdner krankenhäuser
wir haben in anderen regionen in sachsen
wo inzwischen patientinnen in andere
landkreise vorlegen
wir sind an dieser grenze und um es
pathetisch zu sagen und zu wiederholen
es geht schlichtweg um gesundheit und
leben wir sind bild und wie er liefert
dir deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren